And finally,
New Rule here
in the season of giving.
Can we at least agree
that giving is good?
I bring this up because
one of the more
mind-blowing stories
of this year was about
the internet celebrity, MrBeast,
and how he was always
getting raked over the coals
for a series
of charitable endeavors.
Now, if you don't know,
MrBeast is the most
successful YouTuber ever
with over 38 billion views.
Feel old now?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Anyway, he takes
some of the money
made from 38 billion views,
and plows it back
into doing things like,
this year, partnering
with a group of doctors
to provide cataract surgery
for a 1,000 blind people,
that restored their eyesight.
-Cool, huh? Wrong!
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
He filmed
their overjoyed reactions,
which to many made him
a performative altruist.
A Washington Post reporter
tweeted...
And BuzzFeed agreed...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(GUESTS LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
Okay, disability is something
that needs to be solved.
(GUESTS CHUCKLE)
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING,
CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
And what truly needs curing
is blindness.
Here's how I know this.
-♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
-The newly sighted people
are cheering, not booing.
Because MrBeast,
whoever the fuck that is...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
...just cured them
and you didn't do shit.
You know the expression,
"Shit or go blind"?
You did neither.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING,
CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
(SIGHS, CHUCKLES)
I tell ya,
I-- I don't get the woke.
They love nothing more
than being a victim,
except when they really are one,
and then they tell you,
-"I am not, go fuck yourself."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Get the-- Get this. Uh...
Last month, MrBeast,
in another dick move...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
...funded the construction
of a hundred wells
across five countries in Africa
to provide clean drinking water
to half a million people.
-Good thing, right? No.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Not good, bad. (SCOFFS)
The founder of a charity
called Face Africa
called it...
Yes, but...
(CLICKS TONGUE, SIGHS)
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
But you know
what else is frustrating?
Dying of thirst.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING,
APPLAUDING, CHEERING)
(BILL MAHER SCOFFS SOFTLY)
"Man. MrBeast,
how dare he come in
-and bogart digging the wells?"
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
"That's so White guy!
Always taking fresh water
and shoving it
down our throats!"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Oh, another thing
this asshole did in Africa...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
...was pay for the rebuilding
of an African orphanage,
which the director
of the Hope and Homes
for Children charity
called it...
-(CLICKS TONGUE)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
So true.
Ask any orphan to name
the worst part of their life.
"Show-offs"!
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, CHEERING,
APPLAUDING)
Please. Please.
We should be celebrating
having dead parents.
-Hey, it didn't hurt Batman.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
(HESITATES) How did we get
to this weird place,
telling people who are actually
out in the world
making a positive difference,
"You're the problem"?
Yeah, um, quick question.
Who the fuck are you?
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-BILL: And--
And this isn't only the media
and the people on Twitter
who exist to bitch,
always finding something.
"He just did it for the clicks,
or for the wrong reason!"
Or, "He should have done more,
or sooner, whatever.
-You suck, signed X."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-No. No, no.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
No, the--
This is... this is also
the National Institutes
of Health, which last year,
proposed to amend
their mission statement
to exclude
the word "disability,"
saying it, quote...
-(INHALES, SIGHS HEAVILY)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Let me take this moment
to go on record.
Folks, if--
If I am ever struck blind
or deaf, or paralyzed,
don't praise me, fix me.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-Don't--
Don't-- Don't sit around talking
about how much
I'm just as good as you. Fix me!
Do something.
Use AI. Invent something.
Steal body parts
from a pet cemetery.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, CHEERING,
APPLAUDING)
Steal stem cells from a frog.
Whatever it takes!
Gene sequencing,
robotic eyeballs,
harvesting clones.
Inject me
with hamster platelets.
Grow a new gallbladder
from impossible meat.
Just do something!
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
(CHUCKLES)
And if I catch on fire,
you also have
my absolute permission
to piss on my ass.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
You know, there's so much faking
this time of year
between the presents
you don't wanna buy
and the presents
you didn't wanna get,
and the goodwill toward men
that lasts until January 2nd.
-(INHALES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I just don't have room for,
"And disability is awesome."
It's not awesome.
And it's not
a political affiliation.
That's the problem.
We turn everything into
a political identity category.
"You're deaf,
that's your identity.
Don't mess up
a good thing by hearing."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
(SIGHS)
When, uh, Adele lost weight,
she was excoriated for betrayal.
To-- To who?
She betrayed the unhealthy?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
The woke have even turned
the homeless
into a political identity group,
as opposed to liberals,
old school liberals,
who just want to get them
off the street,
which now is seen
as kind of judgy, like...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
...don't disturb them
in their natural habitat.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(GUESTS CHUCKLE)
They're... They're just...
They're just living
their best life
-under the bridge.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
The woke think
the number one job
is to protect homeless people
from stigma.
I think the number one job
is to protect them from rain.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING,
CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
(CLEARS THROAT)
Speaking of which, when I did
the ice bucket challenge
back in 2014, I thought
I was helping the cause
of funding research
to cure ALS. Wrong again!
An op-ed
in Time Magazine said...
It was suggesting no such thing.
What is wrong with this country
that so many people
can't be happy for anything,
for even a second?
Ice bucket challenge?
America is more ready
for the "Can you shit
on something good?" challenge,
and yes, we're up to it.